Bonnie Wright's 10-year stint as the world's
favorite wizard kid-sister turned her into
a plastic-hating, theater-loving mother.
Sometimes growing up can be a magical thing.
Bonnie Wright started casting her spell on
the big screen in 2001's "Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone," appearing as Ginny
Weasley as her older brothers and Harry
board the Hogwarts Express. She joins them at
Hogwarts a year later in "Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets," which finds her being
controlled by Tom Riddle, later revealed to
be a younger version of Lord Voldemort.
Ginny is briefly spotted in "Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of Azkaban" and "Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire." Her character becomes
a steady presence as she builds her relationship
with Harry. Wright also noted that her one line
in "Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone"
wasn't added until they went to film the train
station scene that helps catapult Harry
into his first wizarding adventure. The
completed scene shows Ginny wishing Harry well,
a suggestion made by director Chris Columbus.
"Walk straight to the wall between platforms 9 and
10. Best to do a bit of a run if you're nervous."
"Good luck."
Wright, like most of the cast, grew up on
the "Harry Potter" set, and as she became
a young woman, so did Ginny. In "The Order of the
Phoenix," she joins the group at the Department of
Mysteries — where Harry learns about the prophecy
that sets him against Voldemort — and gets to show
her tough side by using an impressive "Reducto"
spell against the Death Eaters pursuing them.
Wright's role is greatly expanded in "The Half
Blood Prince," getting just as much screen time
as she did in the second film. She now plays
a confident young woman who has friends,
a boyfriend, and a place in the Slug Club.
Probably her most vital role in the film is her
relationship with Daniel Radcliffe's character.
After years of crushing on Harry, the chosen one
finally realizes his feelings, and the two begin
to date. She comforts Harry after Dumbledore's
death, fights in the Battle of Hogwarts, and
watches her own children head to her alma mater.
After "Harry Potter," Wright appeared in
various independent films, including three
in 2013. She played Rose in "The Sea,"
based on the novel by John Banville. It
features a man's return to his childhood
beach following the death of his wife.
She then played Georgina, an orthopedic
surgeon participating in a "what-if"
scenario to gain entrance to a bunker
in the case of an atomic apocalypse in
the sci-fi psychological thriller "After the
Dark." The film was nominated for Best Motion
Picture at The Sitges Film Festival, known
as the world's top fantasy film festival.
Wright's final role in 2013 was as
Phoebe in "Before I Sleep." The movie,
which follows a reclusive poet on his search for
peace, premiered at the Heartland Film Festival.
In addition to being an actor, Wright has also
tried her hand at directing. In 2012, she made
her directorial debut with the student film,
"Separate We Come, Separate We Go," which follows
a 10-year-old girl meeting and becoming friends
with a widowed man Premiering at the Cannes Film
Festival and at the Gold Coast International Film
Festival, the 12-minute film was well-received.
She also has directed the short films "Know
Thyself," Fade to Gold," and "Medusa's Ankles."
Wright even has some music videos under her
belt, the first of which being "Sea Ess" by
George Schuster. She continued directing
music videos in 2018 with "Taught You How
to Feel" by Sophie Lowe, "Iguana Bird' by Pete
Yorn and Scarlett Johansson, and "Fallible" by
Maguire. Her next directing project, "Melt,"
was also for Maguire and was released in 2021.
Wright is an active spokesperson for
environmentalism, especially when it
comes to plastic. She has raised awareness
about the dangers of plastic pollution,
encouraging fans and friends to
stop relying on single-use plastic.
She joined Greenpeace in 2017 to highlight
how single-use plastic has negatively
affected our oceans and wildlife and
the importance of beach cleanups.
"I was really saddened to find how much plastic
we found just in that small
hour's worth of trolling."
She participated in the fight against
the Coca-Cola Company — one of the worst
producers of plastic pollution,
according to Greenpeace — to stop
the production of billions of
plastic bottles. Wright said,
"I'm happy to stand with the
more than 585,000 people who
are calling on Coke to phase out its
use of throwaway plastic bottles."
Wright continues to fight for a cleaner earth
through social media by promoting recycled
products, showing the beauty of nature,
and encouraging followers to take action.
In April 2022, Wright added author to her
list of job titles, releasing "Go Gently:
Actionable Steps to Nurture
Yourself and the Planet."
Wright shares sustainable practices that
readers can regularly practice at home,
and those tips and tricks have now become
the inspiration for a television series.
Wright shared the news that she
would be creating a new show on
the "Go Gently" website in May 2019.
She wrote that production wrapped
in April 2023. She wrote while sharing
photos of her team surrounded by nature,
"It was such an incredible adventure through
California and Oregon traversing so many different
landscapes meeting up with so many incredible
humans doing powerful work to protect our planet."
As of October 2023, a premiere
date has not been announced. For
those who can't wait for Wright's
episodic documentary to premiere,
she does share ways to practice
sustainability via Instagram and YouTube.
In 2013, Wright made her theater debut, sharing
her acting talents in the play "The Moment of
Truth," which focuses on a government that is
facing doom as war is on the horizon. The 2013
production marked the first time that the play had
been performed in London since 1951. Wright played
the role of The Girl during the show's four-week
summer run at the Southwark Playhouse in London.
She told WhatsOnStage that she in no way resembles
her character, which is why she enjoyed playing
the part. And apparently theater is something that
she has always wanted to explore. She said that
she felt like she was trying to navigate an ocean
during the first few days of rehearsals, adding,
"But I am loving every moment of the challenge,
every day I feel like I am evolving in some way."
Amid her successful acting career and push
to protect the planet, Wright is growing her
family. In April 2023, she and her husband Andrew
Lococo announced that they were expecting their
first child by posting a photo of the couple
on Wright's Instagram. She wrote in the post,
"What a wild and humbling journey pregnancy
is, transforming to make space for new life."
She has since been chronicling parts
of her pregnancy on the social media
site and posted videos to her YouTube channel,
discussing nesting and how to keep Earth in
mind when it comes to newborn essentials.
In an interview with Brides, Wright explained
that she and Lococo met at a New Year's Eve
party in 2018 and got engaged in September
2021 with a ring designed by her parents,
Gary Wright and Sheila Teague, who created
the jewelry company Wright & Teague. Wright
and Lococo tied the knot on March 19, 2022, at
a California farm owned by friends. They focused
on using sustainable materials for the wedding
and made a lot of items themselves. She said,
"We loved the idea of being surrounded by
bountiful growing nourishing
plants as we said, 'We do.'"
The wizarding world story has since continued on
stage in the play "Harry Potter and the Cursed
Child," which follows the Potter and Weasley
children as they navigate schoolwork and evil,
leading Harry and his friends to band
together to protect their families.
The play first premiered on London's West End
in 2016 and headed to Broadway's Lyric Theatre
in April 2018. Many have wondered if the
play will ever get the big-screen treatment.
Wright told the "Inside of You with Michael
Rosenbaum" podcast that she is interested in
reprising her role in a film adaptation
if the opportunity ever presents itself,
noting that she is currently unaware
of such a project being in the works.
"It's not about our characters. So it wouldn't be
a massive role ... So it would be fun,
but I have no idea if they'll do it."
Years after the final Harry Potter film,
Wright continues to connect with fans of
the franchise. In 2022, she appeared on the
Max TV special "Harry Potter 20th Anniversary:
Return to Hogwarts," taking a walk down
memory lane with other cast members.
"To actually get us all in one place was a feat."
She also stopped by the updated Warner Bros.
Studio Tour Hollywood during a pre-opening
visit in 2021, exploring the Wizarding World. She
said while walking through the magical attraction,
"I was like, 'We were small, we were tiny,
we were babies!' It was a big revelation."
Wright has also taken to social
media to share her perspective on
"Harry Potter" author J.K. Rowling amid
the controversy surrounding Rowling's
comments against the transgender
community. In 2020, she wrote on X,
"If 'Harry Potter' was a source of love and
belonging for you, that love is infinite
and there to take without judgment or question.
Transwomen are women. I see and love you, Bonnie."
She told The Times in 2022,
"I made that comment then and I
still stand with that same feeling,
but it's got to the point where I prefer not to
comment more. It's a subject outside of my input."
While the movies may be over, Bonnie Wright
is still writing this chapter of her career,
continuing to work on different Wizarding
World projects. According to the Wizarding
World website, Wright is just one of
several big names who lent their voices
to the audiobook version of "The Tales
of Beedle the Bard," which is a book made
up of five fairy tales. The audiobook
was released on Audible in March 2020.
While working on the films, Wright also voiced her
character in the video game adaptations of "Harry
Potter and the Order of the Phoenix" and "Harry
Potter and the Half-Blood Prince." She's also been
to the "Harry Potter and the Forbidden Journey"
attraction at the Wizarding World of Harry Potter
at Universal Studios Florida. In 2014, she took
a tour of the park's Diagon Alley with James
and Oliver Phelps, who played Fred and George
Weasley. The trio were given a look at all of
the magic that fans can explore in a video posted
to the Universal Orlando Resort YouTube channel.